las carreteras y los puentes están
destrozados por los morteros y los
misiles en medio de las hostilidades el
ejército ucraniano nos autoriza llegar
hasta la última línea de defensa en el
este de la provincia de jarquín cerca de
la ciudad de kupianzk
jefe de una compañía de la brigada 92
dice que a pesar de que la zona fue
retomada hace meses la fuerza rusa
siguen intentando avanzar y hacen
operaciones de distracción
atacan para recuperar cupiones
fortalecerse y asegurarse la posición
por aquí pasa la ruta hacia luganos que
si lograsen ocupar sería una importante
Éxito para ellos nos encontramos en una
de las zonas calientes aquí en la región
de harquive desde que llegamos hemos
oído diversas explosiones porque rusos y
ucranianos se enfrentan a pocos
kilómetros de aquí con artillería
sistemas de lanzamiento múltiple y
también tanques
muchos de los militares que luchan en
esta zona son soldados con año de
experiencia en el ejército algunos
llevan hasta cinco meses en estas
posiciones desde la que también atacan
con tanques soviéticos
el comandante de carro de combate de
Igor que solo da su nombre de pila por
motivos de seguridad asegura que su
capacidad de respuesta a los ataques
rusos ha mejorado
antes de respondíamos con un disparo A
sus 30 disparos Pero esto ya no es así
Eso sí cavan trincheras muy rápido hacen
muchas líneas de defensa y tienen una
gran cantidad de soldados
los combates también alcanzan a las
aldeas cercanas
ciudad a seis kilómetros del frente y
que teme ser invadida de nuevo los pocos
vecinos que quedan viven en situación
grave de emergencia humanitaria
[Música]